welcome to the interval thanks everybody
for coming out tonight how about a big
round of applause
for the exciting evening we have ahead
of us my name is michael m
uh i'm the producer of uh this series at
the interval
thank you all for being our first
audience here at the interval for our
first salon talk
in our beautiful new space thank you
this moment is really
uh both an end and a beginning and like
the name
the interval which is a measure of time
and a place out of time in a way
this is that interval
basically every talk that we've done
which is numbering uh
over 40 now this is now
it's right about our i think it's our
75th talk i've lost track
uh at the moment of how many of these
talks that we've done now but every
single one of them has been
full to the brim just like tonight and
that makes
any event better and we're so
appreciative of you for
for responding to to the series for
coming out to it these events
a series we call conversations at the
interval
uh are intended to uh be kind of a
partner and a compliment to the seminar
series
without any further ado let's have a big
round of applause for mr mike pinafsky
our speaker andrew lacoste abbey smith
rumsey margaret levy
carolyn winter is jonathan keats
tonight's guest
speaker nate pursely we may be risking
democracy in another part of the country
by him sneaking out to talk to us
tonight
i love trying to summarize our speakers
we have
amazing topics it's going to be
incredible talk uh so
first of all i want to thank michael and
all the folks at the interval
for not only the invitation but the
tremendous work they do to
organize to put together to get the
speakers into shape for the presentation
so
there's a lot behind what you guys uh
see each time you come here i just want
to thank michael n for all the hard work
you've done in making me comfortable
here michael thank you for that generous
and unsolicited announcement
and michael who's been just a wonderful
you've been my
beatrice when he finished up his talk
which you can
you can hear uh it's part of our long
now uh podcast series
um the way he ended it in 2004 was
the future is not a noun it's a verb
and we're never going to stop futuring
and with that let's get some futuring
going on
uh a toast to uh to all of us
thank you for being here cheers
you